dan wants to know are there any common
mistake you repeat over and over again
either way any tips for overcoming them
dan I think I repeat all my mistakes
over and over again I first of all my
thesis on life is scaling the unscalable
which is one big mistake in itself we
just had a meeting with the whole crew
about like all the mistakes I'm making
model of bottom of the funnel things you
know so like you know I'm a big believer
betting on strengths not weaknesses you
know you try to you try to get better as
you get you know go through the process
and and go along I don't know if I'm the
right person to answer this I repeat a
lot of mistakes I continue always I have
good moments for a year or two or a
month or two of not trying to bite off
more than I can chew but then I get
right into it for all the process and
scalability I continue to create things
that allow me to be the bottleneck
though I think this crew and I are doing
a good job of hacking away and we have
an ambition for 15 to be better at it in
my limited time world you know I am but
really these are all hard questions for
me because I really struggle to think
about what I'm bad at because I spend
all my time thinking what I'm great at
and those are a lot of things and that's
where I put my energy and time and
that's why I think I get the permission
and the luxury and the awesome feeling
of having so many of you watched the
show betting on strengths is the grossly
underestimated execution of our time and
that's what I do and I do it well and so
I answered it out of being a cordial
human being but the truth is I don't
give a rat's ass about my weaknesses I
surely don't know how to fix them
because I don't focus on them much once
in a while and that's that oh crap wait
subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe